today I have a very well-known author
and respected businessman we're going to
be talking everything from money debt
and taxes to the corruption in the
financial and the education system
joining me on the show today we have the
author of Rich Dad Poor Dad it is Robert
Kiyosaki Robert welcome to the show how
are you welcome I'm honored to be on
your program no I'm honored to have you
thank you so much now this show is all
about freedom and Entrepreneurship and I
want to explore all of these themes so
let's get straight into this Rich Dad
Poor Dad is the most iconic book when it
comes to
um you know understanding the system
money debt and taxes and I think the
reason is because people can't get that
information anywhere else we're not
taught in school so I want to kick this
off by asking you why is financial
literacy just not taught in schools
that's a very good question you know
like I always ask people what does
school teach you about money and for
most people say well it's not important
I remember I was nine years old in the
fourth grade
and I asked my elementary school teacher
when we will learn about money and then
she looked like his
she had Chopsticks in her hair you know
and she looked like a little witch and
she says to me she says the love of many
is the root of all evil listen we'll
tell you that you should learn that in
Sunday School
so as the corruption goes deep into
religion and everything
so that's why they don't teach money
they think it's some kind of religious
problem or something I really don't
understand it
but that's interesting that you asked
that at such a young age how did you
know to question things at such a young
age well because I went to a rich kid's
school and by accident you know oh this
was in Hilo Hawaii the farthest City
South farther south than Miami I love
Miami
but across the street was Hilo Union
School and direct I mean like I could
throw a football I mean a little
baseball and hit this other school was
Gila Riverside School and Riverside
School was for Rich Kids Public School
but they owned the plantations my
classmates owned the plantations across
the street where the first generation
immigrants to the plantations
and um
so I realized I was poor although my
father was a head of Education Poor Dad
you know
and so that's why I said how come they
have nice bicycles
why do they belong to the yacht club why
do they go to the country club but you
know where it really hit home
because I couldn't make money anywhere
and um so I used to go caddy you know
carry a golf bag and so I'd hitchhike to
the country club and I'm singing the
Caddyshack
and to get a hamburger which was 25
cents I mean it was a lot of money for a
hamburger back then because most
hamburgers were 15 cents in town but
this is a country club so I go to the
back door of the country club and I
order a hamburger
and I looked through the door and
there's my classmates in the Country
Club
and that's when I realized I was poor I
said how come their parents belong to
the country club
and my poor dad the head of Education
can't afford to go there so that's where
the whole thing kind of started clicking
for me and that's why I got back to
Riverside School I also teaching about
the Chopsticks and her hair had pulled
back you know when will we learn about
money
and she says the love of money is the
real evil I heard the same thing in
Sunday school wow so the whole education
system is geared to be anti-money that
is so fascinating religions you know
what I mean too yeah absolutely and but
what would Financial education in school
look like for you what would you like to
have learned Roberts often talked about
how important it is to diversify your
investments in order to build a long
lasting wealth that's why here and
nearly 90 of financial advisors are
investing into alternative assets in
fact Morgan Stanley says that for the
last 30 years including alternative
assets in your portfolio could have
lowered your volatility and increased
your returns that's why Bank of America
has recently recommended one specific
high-performing alternative asset class
Fine Art last year art Prices rose an
average of 29 and Masterworks returned
over 25 million dollars to their
investors in fact a recent Masterwork
sale in late March returned invested
more than 15 realize profits after just
36 Days Masterworks offers art from
Legends like Picasso which is then
securitized with the SEC and broken into
shares you can find master access
filings at sec.gov the links are in the
description each of Masterworks is 12
sales to date has returned a net profit
in excess of nine percent all the way up
to 39 for a George condo piece as a
result paintings can sell out in hours
and due to the high demand Mass Works
have made a wait list so you can get
special access by clicking my link in
the description to invest and learn more
about masterworks's impressive
performance well it was really simple
because my poor dad I finally bugged him
enough you know I said well what am I
going to learn about money is why don't
you ask your best friends father my
classmate and that was Mike in the book
at the changes name for the families
want to be known
and uh so why does Mike why does Mike's
father know about money my rich dads My
Poor Dad said because he's an
entrepreneur
and what's that and what are you he says
I'm an employee am I nine years old I'm
learning two new words employee and
entrepreneur
I want what what's the difference you
know and then my poor dad says well an
entrepreneur must know about money an
entrepreneur must speak the language of
money
I want what
and then my poor dad says and what I
said what are you he says I'm a school
teacher I'm an employee
and what about you why don't you have to
learn to speak about money he says
because all I want is a paycheck and a
pension paychecks and pensions
so that's kind of the you know I'm nine
years old I am totally confused now
so I go across towns a little dinky
little sugar Plantation Talent like I
said my classmates owned the plantations
and the kids across the street at Union
School all union members
they worked for the plantations and my
other you know so I'm going I'm poor so
I sit down with my rich dad who never
went to school ironically
and um he wouldn't teach me about money
either and he kept rejecting me
I didn't realize it was part of the
process he wanted to find out how badly
I wanted to learn and he says and as we
all know as entrepreneurs right
salesmanship begins when the customer
says no and so the more he said no the
more I got in I said well
and so I kept you know going back to
talk to him and all he says get out of
here kid so that was test number one for
my Rich Dad test number two was as if I
teach you you have to work for me for
free and I said why for free he says
because if I pay you you'll think like
you're dead or dead
the rich don't work for money so if
you've read Rich Dad Poor Dad which is
right there the rich don't work for
money and then I'm I'm now all confused
as a nine-year-old kid
and so that's when the whole thing
started about financial education
and I realized you know my poor dad he
was going for his PhD which stands for
poor helpless and desperate
and in the academic world you know the
school teachers most are they don't know
it the good people but they don't know
their yeah and uh My Poor Dad kept
saying well if I get my PhD then I'll be
safe when
PhD what's that so he went to Stanford
he wrote Chicago Northwestern he still
learned nothing about money and so our
kids the young kids that you bought your
generation today they're as brain what
they're indoctrinated Not educated
you know black lives matter critical
race
[Laughter]
um I don't know what woke I I don't know
what the heck is going on anymore so our
education system is more corrupt today
than let's say 60 years ago when I was a
kid
the difference between employee and
entrepreneur is fascinating what it
means to get a paycheck and how that
changes your mentality
um we're going to get into all of that
um and and the whole work culture I'm
surprised I turned out the way I did but
in terms of um Rich Dad Poor Dad you
know you talk a lot about
um assets versus liabilities and many
people were shocked when you said that a
house is actually a liability so why is
it a liability and can you explain the
difference between an asset and a
liability it's a bigger bigger question
here is
you see
the language of money is a very good you
know the definition of the word
so and the good thing about it is you
want to be rich just learn the like just
speak the language of money like if I
wanted to go to let's say Spain I would
learn Spanish I'm a fourth generation
Japanese I want to go to Japan I learn
Japanese
but when you go to a school system you
learn the language of a school teacher
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay taxes get out debt and buy a
house because it's an asset
but all you have to do is learn the
words so my poor dad called his house an
acid and my Rich Dad said your house is
a liability again it's just the Power of
Words and language so the difference
between rich people and poor people are
words and words are free
and when I said oh
and it naturally it upsets the school
teachers who are mostly I'm not not bad
people when I was in 1965 I read the
Communist Meadow Festival by Marx
and as I read I went to military school
in New York and reading the book I
realized my God
my family's communist wow see they
believe in taxes
they believed in you know the abolished
real estate you know today Claude Schwab
says you will have nothing and you'll be
happy
that's all Communist Manifesto stuff
why don't people realize that because
that statement you'll have nothing and
be happy by 2030 is just so um it's so
evil like I feel it in my soul so why
can you and I feel how evil that is but
a lot of people aren't aware of how
that's so communist and so toxic well
because you know in education they use
postmodernist education they don't speak
on specifics they speak in generalities
like wouldn't you say we should all be
equal I mean you wouldn't you wouldn't
disagree with me I do yes I agree we
should all be equal but it's not reality
exactly so the post uh the
post-modernist Communists the Marxist in
our academic system they speak in these
platitudes like equality this that you
know and it's just
it's as non-specific as possible but as
a capitalist I must speak in facts
figures and the history but they want to
change history you know the 1619 project
or whatever that is
and the real fact is you know America
and then we've got to pay taxes well
Mark said uh graduate income tax is
essential for the spread of Communism
and so my father Poor Dad he believed in
paying taxes my Rich Dad didn't again
the word is taxes
and so when you look at what Biden's
doing right now he just he just put in
87 000 IRS agents who are armed
the reason is they're going after you
small business they're going after the
small entrepreneur they can't touch me
you know because I'm not that stupid to
pay taxes and I can do it legally
but that's why I give make fun of my
friends Peter Schiff and Mark Moss you
know they're living in Puerto Rico I
said if you're a real estate guy you
wouldn't live in Puerto Rico you could
live anywhere you want not pay taxes you
know
but again it was Marx who set a graduate
income tax is essential for the spread
of Communism
but the real facts are in 1773 America
was founded as a tax-free Nation it was
called you know against your Homeland
England yeah it was Boston Tea Party we
said screw you were not paying taxes
and so the real facts are America was
founded as a tax-free Nation
then came 1776 was was a Battle of
Lexington and Concord and the Civil I
mean the Revolutionary War just look at
the facts look at history but now these
academic types they want to blur history
they want to use his platitudes like
we're all equal I don't know what else
they use I can't love is love have you
had that one love is love I don't know
what they're talking about yeah that's a
very big statement just show me the
[__] money well and I don't want to
pay taxes on it and I do I do you know I
couldn't say that if I was not legal did
you know that you don't have to pay
taxes you can move to another country
and pay zero taxes legally you might
have seen my interview with wealthy
expat who does exactly this for you
they've helped over 500 crypto investors
and entrepreneurs like in my gajian
Hamza lower their taxes down to zero
percent legally and you could do it too
in as little as just two weeks wealthy
expat will hold your hands and help you
throughout the entire process setting
you up in a tax-free country like the
UAE with the help of tax experts lawyers
and accountants so if you're interested
in paying zero percent taxes then just
book a free call with wealthy expat
using the link in the description below
I'm with you I'm with you so let's
understand how you do it you talk about
you know don't save money in a bank
account so let's start there why
shouldn't people be saving money in a
bank account It's gotta be crazy I mean
look they printed more money in the last
what five years than ever in history
America is now the biggest debtor nation
in history
you know why don't they teach that in
school our debt to GDP a few years ago
was 90 you know 90 percent that were 90
debt to our gross production GDP today
is about 125 so the more they print
money the deeper in debt we get and so
what's happening right now they print
more money to give it to us you know
like stemi checks and all that which
robs us of wealth which is all total
communist marked if you took a stemi
check you're a communist that's how I
see it that's money from the government
I don't touch anything from the
government I did cash my stimmy check
a check but anyway so they increased the
debt right
and now we can't pay it off
and then they're going to raise interest
rates into a recession now
you got to be kidding me this guy Biden
is going to crush this whole country I
mean Europe's in more serious trouble
than we are yeah Germany's in Syria
serious trouble England is in trouble
Japan's in horrible problems China's in
trouble with Evergreen the real estate's
crashing so this whole thing starts in
academics why don't they teach us about
money so they're going to raise that so
the debt's going up we can't pay it off
anymore
they're going to raise interest rates
and tax rates are dropping because the
economy slowed so much their our taxes
are going down so that means the debt's
going to accelerate this is called a
debt spiral or a death spiral I think
we're maybe two weeks to two years out
from a crash because crash in history
and I want to prove I know what I'm
talking about is this book here Richard
has prophecy because a lot of people
make predictions you know but I can
prove I made it this book was written in
2013. it followed the 2008 crash and it
says here why the biggest stock market
crash in history is still coming and how
you can prepare yourself and profit from
it but I'm going to change the title
from why the biggest stock market crash
in history is here um
and I think it's too late for most
people they're going to get hammered I
know it's in the book but what can
people do to prepare for it just an
overview well you have to understand
that when markets crashed that's like
Neiman Marcus having a sale
if Neiman was having a sale would you be
crying I guess not no no no you'd be
shopping you know so I guess sexually
extremely I think about this crash
coming up because in 2008 when it
crashed holy mackerel yeah I backed up
the truck I borrowed 300 million dollars
now this guy Dave Ramsey was a friend of
mine he says live debt free and for 95
percent of the population debt free is a
good idea because you don't know
anything about money
but if you have a financial education
like my rich dad taught me which is Rich
Dad Poor Dad there debt is money
so I use debt to buy real estate at
great prices so today if I want to you
know if I drive a Ferrari I always drive
nice cars or rolls and all this stuff
but a Ferrari is a liability but a poor
person would call it an asset but to me
it's a liability because I got insurance
gas you know all taxes all that stuff so
before I buy my Ferrari I might buy
let's say a mini storage
and the minister was abide with debt and
the cash flow from the Mini Storage pays
for my Ferrari so I get richer using
getting nice cars but of course Dave
Ramsey would say live below your means
well that's good for most losers but you
want to win use debt you you know Drive
the nice cars you know go to Neiman's on
sale I think that's a wonderful idea I'd
rather be rich than some
come sucking poor person you know and I
don't mean they're scum sucking but
why would you want to live poor it
doesn't make sense to me this is the
land of America the free you know I'm in
Miami this place is spectacular I'm
going whoa I should move here because I
know I had to leave Hawaii
because Hawaii is a communist republic
you know Forbes call it the communist
republic of Hawaii and I own a beautiful
home right on Diamondhead and all that I
just can't stand the energy there
everybody is a communist they're all
labor union people and all this and
that's that freedom I mean I support
their freedom to be that
but Hawaii is also one of the most
racist States I've ever been there
because as you know that's where Obama
is from you know it's one of the biggest
races I ever met
and um you know he's from and he wasn't
a poor kid he was a rich kid
he went to Punahou school I couldn't get
into Bono not be well I couldn't afford
it but I was not smart enough either so
but he and he is as racist as they come
I'm going so in Hawaii I hate to say
this but they're racist against white
people so I have friends who are leaving
Hawaii in droves right now who are white
they call them howlies in Hawaii
you know because the locals the natives
and the especially the Asians don't like
white people
so it's all this oh [__] I mean
you're as a racist as they come I mean
you don't like white people and I see it
on boards and you know in the banks and
all this stuff
so I just watch what people are doing
not what they're saying you know OCTA
non-verba these not words I don't listen
to what a person says I watch what they
do that is all so fascinating number one
I didn't know who I eat was racist
um everybody's racing everybody's racing
everybody's racist what your race was is
man your heart who cares but anyway
I get it
um but uh we're gonna I'm gonna I want
to touch on the financial crisis and the
300 uh million dollar loan that you took
that's that's crazy I'm excited to hear
how that works out but
um in terms of banks I want to go back a
little bit you say that Banks run the
world what do you mean by that can you
elaborate well I mean Obama again nice
boy give me a break give me a break he
was one of the biggest Estates in Hawaii
and and then we have trouble in Hawaii
with walls and stuff like this of course
he gets a wall put in nobody everybody
else in the house is being Swept Away by
the environment you know but Obama gets
to put a wall in oh really
you know I'm going I watch what a person
does not what they say
so he also what he also did in 2008 and
who did he bail out he bailed up first
General Motors then the banks did he
ever help the middle class who were
losing their houses no always watch what
a person does
not what they say why did that happen
though why the bank's getting bailed out
why is it so important to protect the
banks
do I mean you know I mean it's a um I
I don't know why but it starts from an
academic system
that's where in our our teachers speak
the language of a school teacher
I speak the language of a capitalist
you know I know there's been an asset
and liability
I know what bailout means if you read
the book The Creature From Jekyll Island
was with my G Edward Griffin it's the
book on how the Fed was created it's
Jekyll Island I think in 1913.
is the opening chapter is the name of
the game is bailout so every time I
everything that Banks get trouble the
whole system is set up to bail out the
rich
oh really no they wouldn't do that I
mean we're supposed to be equality and
all this stuff no
no this whole setup is for to protect
the banks and Wall Street and those guys
that's why I don't save money I borrow
money that's why I don't own stock spots
mutual funds and ETFs like Tony Robbins
recommends I won't touch that stuff
and I don't trust the school system so I
I'm an entrepreneur I can create my own
assets I don't need to buy them from
Wall Street or the banks so let's define
that the difference between good debt
versus bad debt because you said you
know most people shouldn't get into debt
because that would just wipe them out
so what's the difference well good debt
makes you rich that's real simple so I
buy you know I bought this property in
San Antonio with my friend Ken McElroy
he's the genius he wrote the book ABCs
of Real Estate
for me okay I mean for us
but the San Antonio property that
crashed and it was mismanaged by the
owners they stripped all the copper wire
of the place they took all the fixtures
out and then suddenly it was in
foreclosure so that's why a lot of
entrepreneurs do they they take the acid
and strip it okay
so I'll walk into this place and in San
Antonio's I think I think it was 18 or
20 million bucks it's a toilet sitting
in front in front of the fireplace
there was no no copper wire in the walls
carpets all taken out and I'll look at
his Builder you know
Builder goes oh this is a good deal
it was the biggest wreck I ever saw so I
think we picked up let's keep it simple
we bought 20 million dollars with debt
because the bank wanted to get rid of it
because it's a liability to the bank
because nobody's paying on it and the
taxes are not being paid so we pick it
up for like 20. we fix it and this is
again the language of money we increase
nry net operating incomes the moment we
rehabbed it was all borrowed money
we got the rent up the net operating
income increased and then it was a now
let's say from 20 million to 40 million
and most people would flip it right oh
I'll get 40 million bucks
you don't flip because the moment you
flip it you have capital gains tax
so what we do is we borrow out the
equity and we bought more property oh
wow so debt is tax free if you can
understand that one
so that's how powerful the banking
system is I'm not against the banks I
like debt I mean tax-free money which is
debt
so everybody and like Dave Ramsey oh
lift that freak living Bill your means
I'm going why you don't have to if you
knew the language of money
so how and why is
um debt tax free because the banks
control it because if you don't have
debt the economy stops
the only way money is created if you
understand the macro of money which is
George gammon's world you know that's
where we met yeah
if we don't borrow money there's no
money created so only until I go to the
bank I'll use my credit card
one moment I borrow money
that's when money is created so debt
money is created out of debt
so as Savers they don't want you they
don't want your money a savings is a
liability you know why because the bank
has to pay you interest on it they don't
want your savings they want your credit
card debt if you understand that
everything is opposite let me say this
one all coins have three sides heads
tails and the edge of the coin
Financial intelligence will stand on the
edge and see what's right and what's
wrong on both sides that make you mind
it but our schools say well this is
right this is wrong
that's why School teachers are they
don't even know they are they believe in
labor unions look at the pilots are on
strike right now for the labor unions I
would never join a labor union not that
I say it's wrong I'm not a communist I'm
not a Marxist workers of the World Unite
that was Karl Marx how about the
elections Stalin says it's not who votes
that counts it's who counts the vote
that counts but back to the whole um
printing money inflation not saving
money like you mentioned in the most
unprecedented amounts of money have been
printed in the last two years since
covid so what would you recommend people
do now what should they be buying what
asset should they be buying I I don't I
don't give Financial advice you know I'm
I'm always on Fox and all that talking
about gold and silver pickles and gold
and silver or God's money and there's
Bitcoin which is people's money
and then there's fake money or fiat
currency the US dollar the pound the Yen
the peso
but the most important thing is I'll say
again money is just a language just
words and words are free but until you
change the vocabulary in your head and
learn the language of money like if I
was going to live in Japan I'd learn
Japanese I don't speak Japanese
fourth generation I don't have no any
plans it's not going to move to Japan
because their economy is worse than ours
and the you know the people are good
people and all that but I just don't
want to live there like I don't want to
live in Hawaii because it's too woke you
know I'm down here in Miami I'm going
I'd rather live here than in Hawaii it's
great yeah you should move I do what I'm
saying so I moved out I moved out of
Hawaii California Oregon
they're all so left they're all so
academically politically correct
nauseating I I just don't want to be
around them I'm not saying they're bad
people please hear what I'm saying
you're entitled and I I fought in
Vietnam twice as a marine helicopter
pilot went down three times you know I
fought for freedom I didn't fight for
Republicans I didn't fight for
Democrats I didn't fight for liberals I
didn't fight for conservatives I fought
for freedom so if you want to be a
communist you're free to do that that's
what Freedom means you want to be a
capitalist you're free to do that but if
you read The Communist Manifesto was
coming in two stages 1930 was a takeover
of Academia 19 and 2020 was
um
Twitter
and then
you just look at the facts
so the last two given you know you
protected Freedom um Vietnam the last
two years with covid must have been
um shocking for you well it was a
titanium was coming that's that's what
I'm saying I I show this book not to
sell the book
but I hate it when people say oh yeah I
said this was coming I said well prove
you said it
this is what I did
this is what I do listen to what people
not what they say but what do they do
what are they doing not what they're
saying words are cheap
you know
so that's what I'm saying I did it I
just want to show you I did this thing
and this was 2013 that was nine years
ago and the stock market crashes here
and the stock market crashes it's not
just stock it's going to be real estate
it's going to be stocks bonds and um as
Fox bonds real estate and something else
but anyway we're crashing now
that's like Neiman Marcus having a sale
I'm excited yeah yeah so that that 300
million dollar loan which you took
during the 2008 crash amazing
opportunity
um how do you go about borrowing that
much money and then also how do you
service a loan like that
the property pays for it I don't pay for
anything
and understand this the banks have to
lend money they don't want your savings
that's why oh you should say money why
would I do that when that quantitative
easing idiot why would you do that when
they're printing more money than ever in
the history of the world why would you
save money when America is the biggest
debtor nation in world history you've
got to be really effing stupid
you know you probably went to school
you're probably a school teacher I'm not
saying they're bad people they just
don't speak the language of money so the
reason I can borrow that money is
because when that property went down it
was a liability to the bank and I said
guess what sweethearts you give us the
money we'll fix your problem they said
how much do you want
and you know I'm just using brown
numbers because it's been a while ago
let's say a 20 million dollars they gave
me the money for everything and to fix
it and then they got the noi net
operating income again that's vocabulary
of a real estate guy stock guy speak a
different language okay so real estate
guy says no why is this vocabulary is
this words words are free learn the
language
and so they said okay so we got the net
operating income out and they said do
you want to flip it I said no because
then I have a tax consequence it's
called capital gains don't sell anything
so we borrowed out the 20 million
dollars we bought 10 more properties
that's how you get rich you have to
learn the language vocabulary of money
and that's what not what I'm saying what
am I doing
and is it because of capital gains why
you just won't touch the stock market
you won't touch Amazon stock market you
don't trust it I can make my own asses
I'm a full-blown entrepreneur doesn't
mean I don't have stocks but there's
stocks in my company I created on July 8
I took my first company public on New
York Stock Exchange I've taken public
before on Toronto Stock Exchange I'm a
capitalist I'm an entrepreneur
you know I so I took I took my gold mine
on the New York Stock Exchange with the
help of a Canadian friend of mine and
the gold mine this time was in Provo
Utah Mormon land
oh you're you're anti-religious no I
just said they're Mormons out there my
friends are Mormons I like Mormons I
like anybody we're not Communists but
anyway and Mormons are very very good
with money as a general rule okay
they're very very good but this is a 140
year old Goldmine it was just sitting
there
and this friend from Canada called up a
young guy about your brother's age there
he calls up and he says guess what I
said what I said
I think they missed the vein he said
what
140 years ago they missed the vein said
well how do you know that but he said
techie
so he went into the 140 years of Records
he had it digitalized and they put all
the miners and the old guys you know the
little picks and shovels and all this
stuff
and he he put it and he could put it in
pictures and he says look they missed
the vein so they struck gold it was a
good high producing gold mine for 140
years but the biggest vein was seven
feet over
oh wow and so all they did was they went
sideways for about seven feet they went
oh my God
this is the richest gold mine in the
world
we got it for nothing
and we took it public incredible so you
don't need the stock market
I I do to to sell your own stuff sure
you have to sell your own stats shares
you know Tony Robbins is big on ETFs and
all that and all that stuff because
that's what his son sells yeah there's
always an agenda in there you know
Tony's a good guy smart boy
but he's not a capitalist like me he's I
mean he doesn't take companies Public
public that makes a lot of sense you
said something earlier which I want to
touch on I'm going to actually quote it
because I want to make sure I get this
right um You said in a video if you pay
um sorry you said if I pay you you think
like an employee yeah and your brain
will change and if you learn never to
work for money you'll be a rich man so
this was fascinating I really like this
so can you explain this philosophy in
further detail what changes in the brain
when somebody gives you a paycheck
well because
first of all paychecks are taxed well
there you go okay and then you get
addicted to it you look at the people
that are in trouble today they're
terrified losing their paycheck if
you've never had a paycheck you're not
ever worried
I don't need a paycheck I can go a bank
and borrow money I can create an asset
and sell it you know as long as I have
to pay Capital Gains but that's again
let me just say this
money is a language it's a vocabulary
words are free
but if you don't change the words the
vocabulary in your head that's like me
sitting in Japan wondering why nobody
will speak to me well I don't speak
Japanese
so most people I was saying 90 you know
especially here a lot of people are
small business owners yes they're not
capitalists they're small business they
pay guess who pays the highest taxes
small business yeah I don't pay anything
so that's why when Biden's is going to
appoint 87 000 IRS agents I know who
he's going after yes he's not going
after the employees he's going after a
small business why do you think they're
doing that well because small business
can't afford the attorneys and the
accountants to fight them why do they
want to go to war with the middle class
because that's what um
that's how it was what claw Schwab wants
and why does cloud Schwab want that
because someday you'll learn nothing and
then you'll be happy what's the greater
agenda
bro another book just came out this year
it's called the capitalist Manifesto
yeah and all it is is quotes I mean
we've been warned for so many years like
I said I read The Communist Manifesto in
1965 I was 18 years old I went to school
in New York
and my economics teacher didn't go to a
woke
snowflake University
he went to West Point he was Military
Academy okay and during World War II my
my instructor my economics economics
teacher was a B-17 pilot he went down
and came back the president of War still
escaped and all this stuff so like so
I'm 18 years old sitting in his class
and instead of reading you know the you
know the great economists are like
Malthus Kane's Ricardo Adam Smith and
all those guys he didn't have us read it
our economic teacher had us read Marx
Stalin Lennon Mao Hitler
and I want holy mackerel and so when I
read the Communist manifest only 50
pages yeah I said
my family's communist they believe my so
when I graduated from Kings Point U.S
merchantment Academy I refused to join
the labor union
My Poor Dad
head of the lady reunion of course
Hawaii State teachers Communist Party
All right so he teaches I'm not saying
they're bad people I understand you have
the freedom to believe in what you want
to believe in but if you don't know what
you've been put in your head
you know your kids are sitting in school
right now getting stuff put in their
brain that's actually Marxist or Stalin
or Lenin or Mao and who guess who's
killed the most people communists
you know you look at you know I was a
U.S marine I joined the Marines for one
reason their mission is to kill people
I'm they're very clear on their mission
if you want to kill people as a pilot
right
you don't want to kill people join the
Coast Guard you know it's it's really
quite that black and white clear you
know so I said well if I'm going to go
to Vietnam I didn't have to go because I
was drafting semp because of my my
industry was oil I'm an oil man I went
to school to learn to drive oil tankers
today on oil wells you know
that's how education paid off for me I
don't know Oil stock I own oil wells I
sell oil I don't sell stock yeah that's
the difference anyway so um
I'm sitting there like listening to this
teacher going I think
I
I just don't want to join a labor union
no
no and so since the Vietnam War was
still on I didn't have to go if I was
going to fight
what do you want to fight with
a bunch of guys carrying purses or guys
carrying a gun you know what I mean oh
yeah you know what I mean I do I am a
marine I speak like a marine I am a
marine and in my core my values are very
very Marine Corps my attorney is
Airborne 82nd Airborne we come from
different value systems
you know and we're as tough as nails
and so every time I hear these walk
snowflake University people and going
what are we doing to the young men of
this country
you know today the biggest problem is
too many boys have been raised by their
moms because the guys are flaking out
and then they go to school and get
taught by women School teachers
and today I hear a woman complaining
well there's no men out there I said
well
because they they're taught by
their mothers fem Centric systems yes
and then you know I said well let's let
the boy go into the girls restroom
uh as a guy I wouldn't mind but there's
better way there's better way to get
your Cheap Thrills
and so it's so messed up
and um
but I am a hardcore U.S marine
you know I did some horrible things at
War I was a Gunship pilot well life
expectancy of 30 days
30 days
if I didn't want to live 30 days I would
have flown transports like a ch-47 or
ch-53 different different Mission but
gunship Pilots got in close and killed
people we were crystal clear in our
mission our duties I went down three
times my biggest job
was to get my home my crew home in one
piece we all came home in one piece no
injuries no broken limbs no missing legs
that was my job
and I never fought to kill I fought to
be brave to prove I could do it I fought
for courage I fought for our freedom
then I came home I landed Norton Air
Force Base in California the People's
Republic of California and I got Spit On
by the hippies in the Woodstock
Generation The Love The Love Generation
not getting spit on wow I think Nancy
Pelosi was in that crowd not sure but
anyway you know this sounds like her
crowd I know I'm going
and then my um the guy in charge of all
of us he says ladies and gentlemen this
is what we fought for I'm like what do
you mean he says we fought for the
freedom to spit on us
wow that's a U.S marine yeah he says we
just can't kill him I said okay good
that's a that's a very uh powerful way
to uh you know show the importance of
freedom of speech and freedom in general
um yeah so I fight back with financial
education yeah
that's the only reason what they don't
teach in school and you mentioned uh you
sort of touched on the war on men which
is quite interesting do you feel like
there's a there's a greater war in men
than there is on women do you feel like
there's this focus on sort of feminizing
men is that what you're saying yeah
in the Mel in the Marine Corps they call
it short Army inspection
pull down the zipper you don't know
what's underneath there anymore or in
Spanish you know if we're in
Miami's no balls you know there you go
yeah I've never met a swishy I mean it's
so it's your freedom you might act like
a swish you know it's up to you
but I'm a marine I'm a man now the good
thing is there's fewer fewer men which
is good for me it is yeah less
competition for you on the market there
you go
um but why there must be a reason why
they're trying to and I'll use your word
create more swishes
them a nice plan
because they're all fight back same as
why they want to defund the police why
they want to take away our guns the men
are men are the weapon men are men are
the ones that go to war men are the ones
that protect us basically generally yeah
women got a war now but when I was in
Vietnam
um the women were nurses and they were
just as Brave as the men of course my
friends at my my attorney is again he's
uh 82nd Airborne 82nd airborne's culture
and values are very similar to Marine
Corps very very strong you don't screw
anybody you tell the truth you fight
hard
and I found that his wife was an Army
Nurse in Afghanistan
and I and I said where is she and we're
at a party in Phoenix and I ran I went
up to I just gave her a big hug and
thanked her she says what's this for I
said because there are times as a pilot
sometimes we
you know we picked up bodies on the
field
and so we'd have bodies with guts and
all this stuff blown apart I don't know
how they were living
and I fly into the mass Mash hospital at
China Beach
outside of Danang in Vietnam and these
women these nurses would come out just
drag the bodies off
and we just take off you know like this
get back to the fighting
I never said Thank you to them
so when I met his wife because that's
what she was doing in Afghanistan
I used to give her a big hug and said
thank you thank you for being a very
very strong woman
my wife's a very strong woman but we're
separated
she got enough she had enough of the
Marine Corps stuff for me oh really it
was too much
well I'm pretty much of an [__] I'm
pretty I'm pretty Macho you know she
says I don't I don't you know you're
just too strong all the time
she says you're always fighting I was
arguing I was doing this stuff I'm going
would you rather have me carrying a
purse if you want to carry a purse and
wear a lipstick that's up to you it's a
free country I don't I don't really care
I don't care who you sleep with it's
none of my business I like pretty women
I know you do I know you do I saw you
and oh my God
I'll come here and do any interview you
want oh no I appreciate you coming here
but a lot of these problems you know you
always say sort of stems back to the
education system
um and the lack of financial literacy so
what would you say the three most
important types of incomes are that
people must know about
well this earned portfolio passive uh
earned is when you work for money your
savings are earned income that's where
your tax the highest
and then passive income is income from
um stocks and bonds generally oh no no
part that's portfolio capital gains
portfolios when you buy low sell High I
never sell I have an asset I keep that
asset
and then
um portfolio income is capital gains and
passive income is cash flow
so that that was the whole thing that's
my my board game is cash flow and people
said why did you create the board game
cash flow because another great
entrepreneur in education is Maria
Montessori and she said what the hand
does the Mind remembers what the hand
does the Mind remembers again these not
words not what a person says what are
they doing
so I was add you know I was really I
have no attention span
but my rich dad taught me playing
Monopoly
and so I would go work for him free
because he says if I pay you you'll
think like an employee
so I worked for him for free then he
would teach me about money playing
Monopoly and we all know the formula for
our green Hotel before greenhouses one
red Hotel
so today I own red hotels
and lots of green about 12 000
greenhouses can you tell us more what
your portfolio looks like so real estate
gold Commodities Bitcoin
well I'll tell you what I'm investing in
today okay because it goes to what I was
taught with the 5gs so you know in this
book here prophecy why the Market's
crashing it's come in markets crash in
three phase I go one bounce two bounce
three so right now with boom boom
it's going to crash again
then go up and down now that's bad for
my generation of Boomers because they're
the first generation into a 401k that
happened in 1974. these are the facts
just check out the facts
so 1974 My Generation got set up with a
401k
so they're going to get wiped out
you know so you're gonna so if your
parents are my generation you might have
new roommates yeah they're gonna they're
gonna lose their houses they're going to
lose everything the other thing that's
going to happen to them is that they're
going to the biggest expense come to the
last 10 years of your life called
medical expenses
so
with that knowing all that again seeing
the facts and figures on demographics
um
I own retirement homes
because they have to go there yeah and
the average the average low-income
person is going they're going to be
charged a hundred thousand a year to
live in a retirement home
so I own those things
I also own food
so I invest in wagyu Bulls
because it's a brand Japanese Bulls
so when I was like 15 you know my
friends and I would go to the dairy in
Hilo Hawaii
and we're watching The Bull and so the
Bulls sat there and they brought the
cows in you know and the boat just had
sex all day long
so we're 15 years old I said
I want to be a breeding bull
because you know Noah's a kid right you
know that looks like fun
so this guy's breeding away so so I
bought a wagyu bull
and what we do is we sell the semen
so it's packaged oh wow so that seems
unusual can impregnate like like you
know one ejaculation impregnate like 100
cows and I get a percentage of every
calf
that's incredible so that's food and why
wagu as a brand the rich will always
have money
you know so I live in places where the
brands are like I live in a place called
Brays Island South Carolina
because that's where the rich hang up
there's a book called Anne rand's Atlas
Shrugged that when the crash came the
capitalists went into hiding
and when I found
um Brays Island South Carolina I said
this is where they're hiding so my my
next door neighbors and all that all
hardcore capitalists the rich people
and unfortunately as you guys know with
the rioting and all that the poor
getting slaughtered in the cities it's
really really frightening today
so that's another thing so that's I own
gold mines I own gold I own tons of gold
I own silver I own Bitcoin but I didn't
own I didn't buy Bitcoin you know today
it's about 20 000 just broke below 20.
but I bought it at six thousand so you
the lesson is financial education
profits made when you're buying that
when you sell so what happened to most
people as it went up they were buying at
the top same as real estate here in
Miami they're buying at the top
I just wait for the crash and so next
crash comes and I'm gonna just I have
tons of cash I can come you know I just
I'm ready to go for the next crash
that's where I wrote this book here it
was a warning
that you can prepare for it but if you
don't have the vocabulary or the words
or the language of money in your head
you're saying well I should save money
or maybe I should get out of debt maybe
I should sell my house and pay the
capital gains do you know maybe I should
put more money in the stock market stock
spawns mutual funds ETFs I don't touch
any of that stuff
I'd rather have Japanese breeding bowls
and it sounds like a like a good
business
um so what made you uh pull the trigger
and actually buy Bitcoin what do you
like about it well because I took stock
trading classes I don't invest in stocks
but it's called options trading so I
took three years of options I didn't
like it but I had to learn how markets
go up and down all markets go up and
down
Rich Dad Poor does about Market
fundamentals and then there's momentum
so all markets go up you know the bull
goes up the stairs yep the bear comes
out the window we're in a bear right now
this baby is coming down hard
so once I understood how it's like I was
a surfer as a kid you know why
also all waves come in sets so you sit
there nothing happening all of a sudden
a set of three will come through and
that's over
so you're waiting for the wet set and
you sort of get out
so the same thing when I'm in any Market
whether it's gold or stocks or real
estate I can feel the momentum of the
market and that's what stock trading
does I don't trade stocks because it's
capital gains I don't pay taxes legally
so because of that but you still have
another momentum of market so I was
watching here in Miami because you're
the hot place right now same as Phoenix
but Phoenix real estate is crashing
right now it's crashing why because
everybody came in
the same as Miami is starting to crash
now because too many people came in
so all the losers come in late that's
why I said your time to get to Miami was
good timing thank you yeah but that's
kind of an instinct
so not that I plan on moving to it Miami
but I'm just watching it right now
because I have friends who made a
fortune here because they were here when
it was early yeah absolutely
so why do you uh when do you start to
see this uh Market recovering well
history was again what's the facts right
the last Depression started in 1929. you
know what it ended
25 years later oh wow 1954. one of the
facts in our opinion what are the facts
the thou hit 381 in 1929 it hit 381 in
1954.
it took a took a World War to pull us
out
and that's what I'm concerned about
being a marine helicopter pilot
the odds of us going to war are
increasing that's not good
it's not good
because I've been to war you know it's
not it's not a it's not a John Wayne
movie
it's not a it's not a uh Tom Cruise Top
Gun movie yeah if you see people like I
said when I
put the bodies in the back of my Eric my
helicopter and flew him into the Mash
unit the hotel in the nursing unit
and the nurses pull them out that's War
you can smell it their guts shed piss
everywhere brains arms that's War
not this Tom Cruise stuff not John Wayne
is not good and that's what I'm
concerned about
to what extent is this all just
destruction by Design
well I think it was written in Carl Carl
Marx's book in 1848 called The Communist
Manifesto that's her out the capitalist
manifest I should have brought a copy
all it is is quotes throughout history
every communist was saying that this was
coming yeah you know Marx in 1840 it
said again
it would come in two stages stage one
was 1930 was socialism 1936 when Social
Security started oh oh is that an
accident oh really
of course was pushed by the communist
School teachers not saying they're bad
people they think differently which
their right to do so
and then he said the next thing what
happened happened in 2020
[Laughter]
and Stalin said it's not who votes that
counts it's who counts the votes we're
warned of all this so I wrote the
capitalist Manifesto to counter it I
wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad because my
positioning statement in capitalist
Manifesto says how do you counter
communism taught in our schools by
teaching capitalism in our homes another
way that they're moving forward with
this control and I know you've spoken
about this is Central Bank digital
currency cbdc's
um so what's your take on them and how
do we prevent against it well it's
coming anyway because it's already here
yes it's already in China and that's it
goes to social credits course so cbdc
Central Bank digital currency
surveillance the same as uh Amazon's
what Siri and all this I don't use any
of that stuff I don't want anybody
surveilling me I am a private citizen
so Central Bank digital currency is they
can track you if you buy a trump book
suddenly your taxes go up or something
and you buy a Biden book you get you
know bonus points they're going to track
you via money so the way you I counter
that which I cover in Rich dad's
prophecy
is basically I stay off this I you know
I can stay off the grid I stay off the
money system
so if if they if and it was just sign
executive order 14067 EO executive order
was just signed by Biden in March this
year for a central bank digital currency
so it's here
Jim records talks about that all the
time
and he's a good man I like him he's a
friend of mine
but he um so the way I'm going to get
around Central Bank digital currency
is that's why I have Bitcoin yes and
secondly unless they nationalize that
too
but I have gold and silver okay as long
as I have gold and silver
I can come to you as I look you know
let's say I
somebody
um cleans my house I saw I'll pay you in
silver coins
they can't track it
yeah and the same as I want to buy a car
I can buy gold coins I want to buy a
house I can use gold coins says JP
Morgan said years ago gold is money
everything else is credit
so and the banking system is built on
credit as you know because if money
doesn't exist unless you borrow it
so that's why I'm already preparing for
cbdc by having tons of gold and tons of
I do mean tons okay literally tons and I
buy it with debt amazing that's why I
want to gold mine in Provo Utah I had a
gold mine in China but they took it
you know that's why I don't like Chinese
food who took it Chinese government they
just took they just took it of course
they're gonna do the same thing here
I understand you know I fought communism
yeah I was in Vietnam twice
and I fought I fought them what the
Marines say we don't start the war but
we end the war and we go in there you
know the Chinese are killed 65 million
people I think Stalin killed like 30
million people Hitler killed 18 million
people
but the United States fights those guys
except now the problem is the battles
inside our school system that's why
parents are now called terrorists by
Biden because they questioned the
Communist School boards teaching
walcism and all what what else they're
teaching
um I know you're also very
um Pro the Second Amendment
um the right to bear arms so I'd like to
understand a little bit more about how
you think that um is important in
America well again that's how the whole
War started you know the Civil War I
mean the Revolutionary War they had guns
if not they'd be paying taxes for the
England okay
another thing I'll say I like Brian
Mayan why am I in Arizona
is I can carry class three class three
is full auto
oh wow see you in Vietnam I carried and
I'm a 60. okay full auto you know
so uh if you see me cruising around
Phoenix with a yoga bag on my side
that's what's inside it's a full auto
M16 with 100 rounds of ammunition
and everybody goes and buys his Glocks
okay you know these little plastic guns
I call them that's fine you know the
trouble with a Glock is for fifty
dollars you can switch it it becomes
full auto illegally so my full autos
uh are legal but I switched clock is
illegal
and they're plastic interesting yeah so
I mean I'm pretty good with guns my
highest score was Rockets I can I was
really good at shooting Rockets
I love them you know because
I really appreciate everything we've
spoken about it's been so fascinating
um but you talk about uh all this
corruption in the system you know you
talk about how people can become
financially free become independent and
not rely on the system
um so have you ever felt at any time
that you might be in danger have you
ever felt like people might try and
censor you at all all the time you know
like um
the most dangerous I ever felt was I
came back from Vietnam in 73 I got Spit
On by these hippies you know like I said
I think Pelosi was in the audience
probably she wasn't but anyway I like I
can see her smiling face
but then I come back to Hawaii and I'm
getting spit on
um
it's 1973.
I'm going what happened to America but
that's what Marx wrote about in 1930
when um Columbia University they brought
teachers over
and you know in 1960 when I was at
school in New York that's when the
writing started and that's when all the
Kent State and all these things they
shot kids there and all this because
they're arming the kids with
indoctrination to go against the system
so anyway I'm like more concerned yes so
I got invited back to Arizona State
University last year I almost didn't go
because the last time I was in my MBA
program which only lasted two weeks
I go to my accounting class in 1973.
I'm sitting there I'm sitting in my
Marine Corps Pilot's outfit big mistake
I get spit on in the classroom
the kids just hated me that's awful oh
God I sort of shot you you know I mean
I carried a gun
because our top secret officer we
carried guns
and so then the accounting teacher
didn't know what he was talking about
because he was a teacher yeah you know I
learned accounting for my Rich Dad
so that's in the cash flow board game
that's in Rich Dad Poor that assets
liabilities cash flow all this stuff
and so I got spit on in the classroom
and I swear I'd never go back to school
again so Arizona State called last year
would you come and teach our honors
program I said you got to be kidding me
I'd rather go back to Vietnam oh wow
so anyway the good news is they per they
prevailed and last Saturday we touched
we taught the cash flow game to their
honors program
and that's really good news and I was
really surprised I was afraid you know
because I didn't know who's sitting in
the audience
and there's the top students the other
good news is Ron DeSantis here
they called us in to put to teach
Financial education in the Florida
school system nice to elementary school
kids so education is changing but
they're going to run into opposition as
you know from most School teachers
because most School teachers have not
read The Communist Manifesto they
believe in taxation labor unions you
know the pilots are on strike now
they're all labor union guys another
thing they don't tell you is this is
that my classmates when he came back
my poor dad wanted me to go fly for
United Airlines I said why would I do
that I had to join the labor union he
says yeah but it's a good job of
securing all this stuff but most people
don't know is the United Airlines Pilots
lost our pensions they got stolen
and there's a thing called the pbgc
pension benefit guarantee Corporation
supposed to back up all these pensions
it's bankrupt
and so I wrote a book here with Ted
sedel some some Fort Lauderdale
and it's called who stole my pension the
next biggest thing you're going to see
is our pensions are bankrupt
they've been robbed and stolen
interesting enough
Biden's top executive his name Gina
raimondo she was a head of um Rhode
Island's pensions
they went bust she stole the [__] out of
them and she got paybacks from all Wall
Street guys I don't trust Wall Street I
don't trust a treasury and I don't trust
the Fed
so that's why I'm an entrepreneur I
create my own assets I don't need theirs
and I have Galls over Bitcoin
and so Biden has this guy woman Gina
raimondo and then you know this crash my
school is shipping I went to school to
be a tanker officer so today I own oil
wells I sell oil I don't sell Oil stock
but the this guy Pete Buddha judge who's
the transportation secretary at the
height of the supply chain credits he
goes on maternity leave he goes on
maternity leave and going
I guess not what they're saying is what
are they doing
what is this guy Biden doing the film
Reserve now is stacked with
what are they doing I'm not saying what
are they saying what are they doing
the academy went to his U.S Merchant
Marine Academy Kingsport New York our
motto was OCTA non-verb these not words
as Marine officers were trained to watch
what a people person does not what they
say you know if I saw a guy who was so
afraid didn't want to go into battle I
had to take him out I mean just say hey
take a break
you're not ready
you know what I mean I don't want you in
the back of my aircraft when I'm
counting on you
and the thing I loved about flying for
the Marine Corps we fought in teams we
go in flights of three and four so I'm
watching the Pelicans fly up and down
the beach here the offline information
civilian Players final loan fly alone
yeah interesting but it's I went to
military school
I fought for the Marine Corps people
said the Japanese Marine Corps no no
American yeah
but anyway that's how
uninformed Americans are because they go
to school and they never learn to speak
the language of money
and the best thing about the language of
money words are free
you don't have to pay for them
if you want to change your life change
your words your vocabulary speak money
there you go where can people uh buy
your books find out what you're up to
where should they go to oh there's
richdad.com I have three projects this
year I'm doing Arizona State now
and so it's a big uh overcame I fear of
that one because I'm on Facebook School
teachers are students number two is
Prager University and I were doing an
event with a guy named um
anyway with Craig Dennis Prager and
Jordan Peterson yeah and we're going
we're going to well do a huge Gala event
in Beverly Hills this November
and the other one and and also in Austin
Texas with Prager
because we're very very they would call
us right wing but we're very capitalists
yes we're capitalists not Communists and
the third thing I'm doing is my roommate
in the on the carrier in Vietnam
well I got court module twice because I
have disciplinary problem s okay
so you have that yeah so anyway I got
kicked out as a lieutenant and he came
out as a lieutenant general so to make
Colonel is really hard okay okay to make
one star almost impossible
he's a two-star he went to three star in
today's a congressman
from upper Michigan his name is Jack
Berger and Congressman Bergen was a
three-star General Bergman
and we bought a house right next to the
Capitol in Washington DC he's going to
live in it is going to be called the
rich dad house nice and we're going to
have meetings at the rich dad house and
people going to walk by all our products
and all that so those are the three big
initiatives for this year one is Arizona
State University Prager University and
our the DC house next to the Capitol
the rich dad house that's what we're up
to amazing it sounds like uh when the
Santa is going to teach Financial
education elementary schools in Florida
amazing yeah it just sounds like there's
so much happening right now to fight all
of this woke culture the communism the
authoritarianism that's coming
um so I love being part of this
conversation Robert I want to thank you
so much it's been such a pleasure I
really enjoy um you know all your books
everything you've taught so thank you so
much for coming on the show oh thank you
it's my honor that's why I ask you who
was your audience first before I open my
big mouth put my foot in it so thank you
very much no this is perfect my audience
will absolutely adore this so simply I
believe in the freedom
like it that's your problem I don't care
you sleep with
stuff like that and I do like carrying
full automatic weapons because that's
what I cared in Vietnam I don't want to
go to a gun fight unless I have a
machine gun
me too I'm not going without a machine
gun I respect that um very Pro Freedom
thank you so much for coming on thank
you thank you everyone so much for
watching if you enjoyed the show please
don't forget to hit the like button and
hit subscribe so you never miss a video